salut à vous pourquoi j'ai fait ça ou
pas ap merde le micro ah oui pardon
salut à vous au mentalist en herbe alors
je dis mentalist en herbe se veut pas
dire que vous deviner les pensées des
tulipes en voici aujourd'hui six
nouvelles énigmes qui vont vous stimuler
et que vous allez adorer je pense raufer
à vos amis si vous n'êtes pas encore
abonné à la chaîne c'est le bon moment
pour le faire pendant le générique
voyez le générique yagg vous cliquez sur
le bouton abonnés en vous en activant la
cloche c'est très bien comme ça
loïc genot vous voici prêt à saigner ces
six énigmes
une partie d'entre elles s'en tirer de
mon livre numérique cérébraux m dont je
vous parlerai à la fin de la vidéo
dites moi dans les commentaires si vous
êtes prêts allez-y loïc tu peux lire les
commentaires alors moi je suis près très
près peut-être un peu trop près et
peut-être dans le noir c'est parti pour
la première énigme
on commence avec un cadenas j'avais fait
ça sur les réseaux sociaux pendant le
premier confinement vous n'aviez pas mal
qui fait sur un style sur facebook alors
n'hésitez pas à faire pause pour
réfléchir
voici des indices avec 684 un chiffre
est bon et il est bien placé avec 621 un
chiffre est bon et il est mal placé avec
436 2 chiffres sont bons et sont mal
classés avec 708 aucun chiffre mais bon
comme ça c'est réglé
et avec 783 un chiffre est bon est mal
placée alors la question c'est quel code
permet de déverrouiller le cadenas
ils demandent vous pouvez faire pause ou
revenir en arrière grâce au chapitrage
cas dans le bas de la vidéo et la
description et la réponse vous la soirée
juste après la deuxième énigme
[Musique]
attention pour cette deuxième énigme je
vais faire parler quelque chose qu'il ne
peut pas parler en temps normal et cette
chose dit c'est étrange parce que quand
on a besoin de moi on me jette et quand
on n'a plus besoin de moi on me récupère
la question qui suis-je
il ya de la logique vous aurez la
réponse après la troisième énigme et la
réponse de l'énigme précédente c'était
314 oui 314 sap et 3,14 c'est le début
depuis toujours on sait il ya une espèce
d'obsession notes reçues pour cette
moitié de test je vous propose un big
bat alors c'est quoi un ding bat c'est
une sorte de rébus qu'à une tendance
graphiques et textuelles
là vous êtes en train de le voir
apparaître sur votre écran voilà à
regarder le étudier le derrière ce wind
pad se cache une personnalité historique
mais qui
jean-jacques je vous donne ce qui jean
jacques lui non plus mais je vous donne
la réponse de la prochaine énigmes et la
réponse précédente c'était une ancre de
bateau
on doit se servir d'une ancre de bateau
mais en jette l'ancré quand on en a
besoin loïc on on a acquis père sur le
bateau comme ça al ahmar à l'ancienne
sinon ils font comme au retour c'est une
table on va augmenter un petit peu la
difficulté attention à bien raisonné
pour cette énigme imaginez que vous êtes
au volant de votre voiture vous faites
un très long trajet de 1000 km à la
moitié du trajet donc à 500 km le gps
indique que vous avez roulé sur une
moyenne d'environ 100 kilomètres heure
donc c'était votre allure moyenne 100 km
h
du coup combien devez vous roulez pour
qu'à l'arrivée le gps indique 200 km h
de moyenne
je vous répète les données vous avez un
trajet de 1000 km à faire à la moitié du
trajet à 500 km le gps10 que vous avez
roulé en moyenne à 100 km heure
à combien maintenant vous devez rouler
pour l'autre moitié du trajet pour avoir
une moyenne globale de 200 kilomètres
heure
prenez le temps vous vous doutez bien
qu'elle n'est pas aussi simple qu'il n'y
paraît et la réponse d'ailleurs c'est à
la fin de la 5ème énigmes et pour le non
bâti
il fallait simplement le lire et compter
les mots pour voir qu'il y avait 4 in 2
mai et
si ce soit catherine de médicis énigmes
et 5 comment nommer trois jours
consécutifs sans dire lundi mardi
mercredi jeudi vendredi samedi et
dimanche
sans répéter juste trois jours
consécutifs
je te connais loïc ou jours jours jours
parce que je te connais le heat je vous
connais aussi donc sans donner de date
de calendrier style trois mais quatre
mais cinq mais c'est pas évident mais
c'est largement faisable
bon courage vous devez nommé trois jours
consécutifs sans dire lundi ou mardi ou
mercredi au g10 votre dit samedi
dimanche sans dire georges jours sans
dire des dates des trois mais quatre
mais tout ça je vous écoute plutôt dans
les commentaires d'ailleurs la côte en
réponse à la fin de la sixième énigme
mais pour l'énigme précédente que
j'adore il n'y a pas de réponse alors
c'est un peu déstabilisant à comprendre
mais pour faire 200 km heure de moyenne
il faut que votre trajet dure cinq
heures 1000 km avec une moyenne de 200
kilomètres heure ça veut dire que vous
roulez 5h peu importe les variations de
votre vitesse
or à la moitié du trajet vous avez déjà
roulé cinq heures puisque vous avez fait
500 km à 100 km heure de moyenne
donc à part vous téléporter à l'arrivée
vous serez forcément en dessous de 200
km heure de moyenne et celle ci elle est
allée triki posé là à votre famille et
regarder les buggy du cerveau
[Musique]
dernière énigme une de mes préférées il
y en a une autre que j'adore que je vous
mettrai en bonus à la fin parce que la
mx m et john cale l'ont déjà fait dans
une vidéo où il prenait mon livre
d'énigmes et aller dedans mais je vous
mettrais l'extrait parlons avant de cet
idiome énigme régulièrement on appelle
le chiffre 2 10 pourquoi et dans quelles
situations il ya une situation où quand
on voit le 2 on se dise c'est 10 une
situation vous connaissez quant à la
réponse de l'énigme 5 vous pouviez dire
hier aujourd'hui et demain c'est bien
trois jours consécutifs ou avant-hier
hier aujourd'hui parle comme ça ça
marchait alors la réponse le qu'il avait
trouvé en vrai tu m'as fait le geste
c'est lorsque vous regardez leur camp la
grande aiguille et sur le chiffre 2
c'est bien qu'il ait 10 en termes de
minutes et c'est pas évident mais avouez
que c'est vrai depuis on n'allait pas
finir sur une facile quand même je vais
donc vous donner mon énigmes préféré un
bonus comme xm et joy qu'elle avait
résolu sur leur chaîne des côtés des
hommes toutes les énigmes viennent donc
de ma boutique en ligne en fait de mon
bouquin cérébraux en question ma
boutique en ligne brainstorm où vous
pouvez retrouver entre autres m'ont pdf
de 150 pages denning qui était sorti
l'été dernier
oui je sais j'en ai jamais parlé sur
youtube il ya aussi des tours de
mentalisme sur la boutique vous pouvez
refaire vous même miam et livia mais
coffret etc
je vous laisse découvrir tout ça je
voulais un lien dans la description et
comme j'avais jamais parlé de la
boutique sur la chaîne je vous mets un
coup de promo qui s'appelle moins cher
merci qu'il sera belle à but semaine et
ça vous fera une réduction de 2 10% pour
le premier et 5 % pour tous les autres
sur toutes vos commandes pendant une
semaine
le lien de la boutique c'est donc dans
la description et voici l'énigme bonus
le 13 mars 1933 un célèbre journal
parisien intitulé le parisien aurait
titrait en première page le colonel du
char héros de la première guerre
mondiale est décédé pourquoi être
certain que ce titre il n'a jamais
existé est-ce que l'imprimerie existe et
du coup j'ai peint
parce que le 13 mars 1906 dimanche alors
c'est quoi la réponse à cette énigme
eh bien vous aurez la réponse soit dans
ses rêves rome si vous voulez vous faire
le blick un soin dans la vidéo 2d côté
des zooms que je vous mets en bas dans
la description également puisque
évidemment ils disent la réponse j'ai
hâte de lire vos commentaires pour
savoir votre score sur les six énigmes
du jour dites-moi également si vous
voulez d'autres énigmes de temps en
temps ça fait longtemps qu'on est en
fait plus sur la chaîne c'était un des
fondamentaux
oui de la chaîne au départ sachant que
j'en fais aussi quand même sur mon
instinct souvent donc c'est vous qui
voyait et n'oubliez pas de les chats les
chiens chats et n'oubliez pas de lâcher
à like c'est gratuit ça est bien la
vidéo prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt
ciao ciao